[Music]
Gil Jones newest book is empires of
light Edison Tesla Westinghouse and the
rates to electrify the world she talks
about it now at the Chautauqua
Institution in New York this is an hour
thank you can everyone hear okay yeah
well I'm really very honored to be here
and especially after I had a chance to
see who all the previous authors were
this is my first time in Chicago but I
feel that I'm in a long line of very
wonderful writers so I feel very humbled
I was asked to talk about how I came to
write a book about this early history of
electricity and I found that this was a
question I was asked everywhere I went
as I was working on this book and when I
went out to promote this book and it
suggested to me that this would not see
as a glamorous
cutting-edge fabulous subject that it
definitely is so I'm going to just talk
in a very I guess sort of meandering way
about how I did come to write this book
and give you some sort of ideas is the
life of the writer it really began with
my first book which I began working on
in 1981 I would suggest in New York City
and I became extremely fascinated with
the history or the stories of South
Bronx which was a suburb of Manhattan
that really sprang up in a manner of a
decade or two in the wake of this
building of the subways but was really
spectacular about the South Bronx the
way it went up in flames
really almost a near-death experience
are some gangs drugs and abandonment and
I think for most Americans they really
became aware of the South Bronx in
nineteen
in Salem when President Jimmy Carter
went to Charlotte Street and it was that
televised backdrop of these half
demolished buildings and this kind of
moonscape rubble and this is America in
the late 20th century were a very
powerful rich country and yet here's the
part of what's actually also the richest
city in the country looking like
something afterworlds were true to and
there's a typical comparison with the
Dresden
I mean was a really quite a spectacular
site and I should also just mention
because I just discovered this at Peter
Davison who was my first editor was here
nine years ago in Tortola as someone at
this microphone so that was my first
book which was about to sell bronze and
I should say that in 2002 I had the good
fortune to do a revised edition and the
title which is South Bronx rising rise
fall and resurrection of American city
and what most people don't know even if
they live in Manhattan is and in fact
the South Bronx has been almost
completely rebuilt it's really a triumph
of the grassroots groups there who act
as they have been become incredibly
savvy real estate operators and
collaborating with Mayor Ed Koch he was
really sick of being I guess dumped on
for the whole homelessness situation in
New York and he committed a billion
dollars to the rebuilding the South
Bronx was a very courageous act with the
new miraculous outcome so it used to be
if you drove across the South Bronx
Expressway you see these empty buildings
and they had the decals on the windows
with little daisies and things to make
it look as if someone lived there now
people do really live in those buildings
when I was working on my book on the
South Bronx one of things that really
surprised
me what to hear people who had grown up
there and watched with great sorrow as
their neighborhoods began to deteriorate
and crumble around them was the role of
drugs and specifically heroin had
becoming really a plague and occurs but
it began in the 1950s and that was
really surprising to me because I'm
doing these interviews in the early
1980s and I thought of the drug culture
is something that really destructive in
the 1960s and these people were talking
about how the drug culture of heroin
really kind of metastasized and then
began to corrode and destroy the social
fabric of the neighborhood that they
lived in and that was really in my first
book led to my second book because I
could not find a book it answered this
question of why America had seemed at
such a powerful drug culture so as you
can imagine the course of working on a
book like the South Bronx I read a fair
number of PhD dissertations and I
thought you know I could do this and
it's a book that I write next I really
got to get myself a PhD and of course of
doing it and in fact when I began to
look into the history of drugs in
America I found that it was it was
complicated and it was very rich and I
really didn't know how to think about it
and so I had moved to Baltimore my
husband went to do his residency at
Johns Hopkins Hospital and I have a very
good fortune to be able to go into study
with John Hyman a cultural historian at
Hakan it was that rare person I wrought
knowing exactly what I wanted to do as
my dissertation which was the history of
illegal drugs in America I had got my
PhD in 1992 and then I continued to work
on and expand this topic and I had again
good fortune being supported by the Ford
Foundation and then also the National
Endowment for Humanities and I signed a
book contract with Scribner published a
book in 1996 I would wanted to call this
book dope which you may be surprised to
know it actually
the one of the earliest historical words
referring to drug it was a Dutch word
which means kind of a gooey black axle
grease and it was a kind of a slang for
smoking opium but unfortunately my
publishers didn't like that and so my
book ended up with the completely hard
to remember hard renounce title hepcats
narcs and pipe dreams now I like the
subtitle history of America's romance
with illegal drugs so as you saw it
seemed like in my second book really
came out of my first book and then when
I finished my second book I was really
didn't know what I was going to do next
at this point really for almost 15 years
I have been immersed in what my husband
called the bummer meet and these are two
books that looked at really you know
very large failures of the American life
and public policy but one thing I did
know is that when I was writing both
these books I was really enchanted with
this the decades that I wrote about in
the late 19th century the Gilded Age
which technically is from about 1877 to
World War one and one of the reasons I
think this is just such a wonderful era
and I think everyone who comes in to
traval WA has probably a stronger sense
of it than your average American because
you participate in what's really a very
Gilded Age kind of enterprise with all
of its richness and sense of history but
the Gilded Age is so wonderful because
it's a era when America becomes wealthy
and powerful it's a big era of
immigration Vanderbilt Rockefellers
Gould Andrew Carnegie JP Morgan and of
course Edison who we've already heard
from know now it appeared
[Laughter]
and wedding ads and these are all people
who who created great new industries and
made great fortunes so it's really in at
the beginning of the United States as we
know it today the other thing that's
great about the Gilded Age of your
historian and writers there's almost no
rules and so people do a lot of bad
things which is makes for good drama at
the same time there's no safety net and
that's also great drama because if you
just cannot imagine from the vantage
point of the 21st century that you know
when you lost a job there was nothing
there waiting for you I mean just Henry
was the very real prospect the other
thing was really interesting to me as I
was contemplating you know what what to
work on next wasn't in fact the
mid-1990s there were very few new books
about the Gilded Age but I did feel that
after writing to bummer be books and
being deeply immersed in drugs and urban
decay that I wanted to write a book
about American success and why America
was such an amazing engine of invention
opportunity and prosperity I grew up my
whole life overseas and so I actually
always I think Tennessee the United
States more with foreign eyes and the
things that mean it always seemed like a
very rich country to me because I grew
up in a lot of poor countries overseas
my father worked for the Agency for
International Development and I lived in
many four places obviously in the state
of great privilege in comparison to
everyone else there the other thing
about my attraction to the Gilded Age
with a lot of my favorite books are from
that time and um that use this backdrop
of of new money and wealth to tell some
really wonderful stories one of my
all-time favorite authors is Edith
Wharton and I have to say
House of Mirth the character in man Lily
Bart I think is just one of the most
compelling and poignant depictions of an
American woman trying to make her way in
a very difficult but wealthy newly
welcomed society I also love Henry
James's portrait of a lady which is
having lived overseas a lot I guess
that's something of an expatriate I
found that fascinating and then David
McCullough who's come here quite a bit I
noticed that one of his books that he
lectured on here is one of my other
favorite books mornings on horseback
about Teddy Roosevelt I also know that
Teddy Roosevelt one of my favorite
gilt-edged characters has also been here
so I felt there is steeped in one of my
favorite eras so I started looking
around for Gilded Age story I in fact I
and I even I would spend a lot of time
researching five different people and I
actually even wrote a book with puzzle
was a really bad idea I could never
figure out how to connect these five
people one of them was a railroad Titan
another one tobacco Titan but it just
never came together until I was you know
really sort of a you know in a state of
being quite stymied when something
happened completely out of left field
and I have to say that is one of the
delights of writing books is it because
you write these books they go out and
they kind of take on a life of their own
you never quite know what's going to
happen you know when the phone rings
these days it tends to happen via email
but out of left field I got a phone call
from the Drug Enforcement Administration
in Washington asking if I would come and
curate a museum in their headquarters
which I found an extremely unlikely
development because I actually had a
very acrimonious relationship with them
and I was writing my book on illegal
drugs because I wanted documents from
them through the Freedom of Information
and which they did not want to give me
but I guess you know icons are bygone so
they invited me to do this well this was
an extremely interesting experience for
25 years they had been collecting I
guess you could call them drug artifacts
ever since 1914 they have had agents all
over the world and for 25 years they had
been collecting things from retired
agents active agent and they literally
had all this stuff down in the basement
of their headquarters in Pentagon City I
mean you went down through the garage
and there were these basement rooms and
they open them up and I have been
spending many years in archives and
libraries and said this was I mean it
was really great fun you know they'd
open these boxes and there would be
these incredible old Chinese opium pipe
drug paraphernalia from court cases in
the 1930s original movie posters from
things like reefer madness or I was a
teenage drug addict and then they had
just a truly astonishing collection with
everything that had ever been used to
smuggle or Tempah smuggling drugs shoes
decks of cards giant surfboards and we
said this was great fun and it sort of
gave me something to do while I
continued to wrestle with this problem
of trying to find a Gilded Age person
sufficiently interesting the carrying a
book and so you will of course naturally
imagine well it wasn't this time that I
ran into Edison and Westinghouse and got
going on to book of electricity but no
I'm telling this is history she was his
story and so that's not how I came
across them the person that I did come
was a man named Alexander Cassatt and
I'm sure most of you have never heard of
him he was president from 1899 to 1906
of the Pennsylvania Railroad and it at
that time that was the nation's most
powerful and important corporation would
be hard to find something comparable
today because there's just so many big
powerful corporations but you might say
it would be someone like Bill Gates and
Microsoft ironically today the person
who's really famous is his sister Mary
Cassatt the painter and of course in
their day he was enormous ly famous and
no one had ever heard of her and so that
is an interesting I guess twist of fate
and fame but the reason that Alexander
Cassatt was famous in his day is if he
saw the huge problem that affects the
Pennsylvania Railroad for 30 years and
that was how to get into Manhattan which
was in those days America's richest and
most important city and not only was it
the biggest seaport in the United States
with the biggest seaport in the world
and the only way you could get to
Manhattan in those days was on a boat if
you were coming from any place but
Albany
everyone just sort of would always
assume there always were tunnels and
bridges into Manhattan but obviously at
some point they had to get built and
Cassatt's great work of genius was to
conceive and see through what was the
nation's biggest civil engineering
project of his day and that if you have
ever taken the Amtrak into New York
you've been in 2/3 tunnels so they came
under the Hudson River they went through
Manhattan and they also owned the Long
Island Railroad they went under the East
River
they built a Health Gate Bridge and then
they continued
on us into New England and obviously the
crown jewel of this whole enterprise was
Charles with him
Pennsylvania Station so Alexander
Cassatt was the person that I found to
write about and carry a really wonderful
guild engaged book and George
Westinghouse and Alexander Cassatt were
all professional friends Kasab had
helped Westinghouse who is the inventor
of the air break perspectives product
and then get it used and made standard
for the whole Pennsylvania Railroad line
and then for almost every other railroad
in the country that's catapulting
Westinghouse into the top ranks of
Pittsburgh industrialists and so in
search of Kasab material I with the two
existing Westinghouse biographies now I
now I have to make yet another kind of
homage to a book that was an influence
on me and that was about the time that
I'm reading these Westinghouse
biographies I'm also reading Simon
Winchester superb professor in the
madman I really love this book I had
read many years earlier caught in the
web of words which was also about the
Oxford English Dictionary and I loved
Winchester's book when it's slice of
history and I thought I would like to
write a book like this because you have
to remember these two earlier books I
wrote each of them covered more than a
century of history and with each
advancing decades you had new cast of
characters I've never had the chance to
write a book just where you had a few
people and you stuck with them through
the whole book so I thought that would
be a really you know a treat so I'm
reading along and Henry proud biography
of Westinghouse when I encounter these
chapters about the war of the electric
current and I have to say they just
stopped me dead in my tracks because I
thought I knew something about Thomas
but what I did not know is that he had
helped develop and promote the first use
of the electric chair
and I thought booming now this is not
the Thomas Edison that I know these
folks II beloved kindly genius inventor
this is a very ruthless businessman
who's prepared to see a criminal die so
that he can smear his biggest competitor
and the war of the electric currents in
which as eNOS and his system of DC are
pitted against Tesla Westinghouse and
their rival system of alternating tron
is actually a very well known episode in
science but it was not a well-known
episode to me because I'm not very well
educated in science so in the summer of
2000 my daughter went to Suzuki camp for
five days and I took with me five books
John O'Neill's biography of Nikola Tesla
these two Westinghouse biography to
attract mansion and then to Edison
biographies one by Matthew Joseph and
Josephson who we know is the author of
the robber barons and then also book by
Paul Israel and it's called inventing
the century which is a wonderful
biography benefit and I spent that whole
week just reading these books by the end
of the week I had my outline and I was
really hooked on this story and I was
very excited now I should mention that I
did not know a single thing about
electricity or how it worked and that my
husband the scientists thought this was
hilarious that I who you know he is a
scientist I should say and with this
total intuitive understanding
electricity that I found extremely
galling and was deeply jealous of him
that I who was a general ignorance on
the subject of science but and
electricity particularly that I have to
write a book about their early history
and development of electricity is a
commercial entity now the other thing
you might wonder is now look at Al
pathology why am i just you know dumping
him
and I actually had at that I was that
far on that book that had actually
written a book proposal you know rough
draft well the thing I knew was the to
write a Kazakh book I was going to make
many many forays to the Pennsylvania
Railroad Archives which became available
probably about ten years ago so you know
say four years ago and her three years
ago and I was working on all this they'd
only been available for about five years
they're up in the state archives in
Harrisburg Pennsylvania I live in
Baltimore such a 90 minute drive is very
doable the thing I knew cuz I'd work in
these archives they're incredibly
labyrinths Eames they are extremely
complicated no one up there really
understands them and they finally
discovered the reason they'd never
bother to master them if they don't
actually really own them an in theory of
any moment the archives could be removed
they belong to some legal entity that's
left over from the demise of the
Pennsylvania Railroad in the new york
central so I thought it was probably
fairly unlikely that anyone else was
going to make as many trips up to
Pennsylvania as would be required
because when they would go the first few
times they would get very discouraged
about every twenty extricate anything
from these archives the War of the
electric currents as its subject on the
other hand something anyone could do
from their house and the reason was that
the s and Archives had gone online is
this Anna mean that the Internet is an
amazing is amazing tool and the editing
archive is a searchable database that
has about a half a million documents in
it it is also not that easy to use but
Paul Israel who is the
managing editor there is a lovely fellow
and I spent a fair amount of time on the
telephone with him staring at my screen
thing well now I don't understand you
know if I click this why isn't this
happening and he guided me through them
and help me find many things Nikola
Tesla basically what there are as there
are a few letters in the Library of
Congress than otherwise he Tesla wrote a
great deal about himself he has a
wonderful voice heard the pure man and
he wanted to preserve his own legacy so
he made sure that he wrote a great deal
about himself and again because of the
internet and a site called the American
book exchange which is where some
significant percentage of the used
bookstores in this country are on that
site on anything
the Tesla ever wrote you will be able to
find that way one thing happens that to
be a much more complicated issue which
I'll talk a little bit about more later
so to write this book you know I didn't
need to leave your house too much except
you know you'd want to go to New York
and I certainly went to Buffalo and
Niagara Falls and Pittsburgh it's not
the same as having to go week after week
month after month up to Harrisburg so I
thought it's probably pretty safe and
putting Alexander Cassatt aside and
dedicating myself to Edison Tesla and
Westinghouse now let me just since I'm
here in upstate New York I'm you saying
something a little bit about my research
trip up to Buffalo also kind of an
unforgettable event I had this romantic
idea that I would take the train to
experience what all those Gilded Age
millionaires and lover barons did when
they go upstate to see what had happened
when there were their investments into
the Niagara power hydroelectric plant
that was being built there and but I
have to say somehow when you're on a
shabby Amtrak car it doesn't really feel
like JPMorgan heading up in his luxury
is private woman but you know I I
decided it was worth a try but I can
sold myself by rereading Lauren Belfort
City of Light and I know that she was
here this was a very influential book
for me when I was trying to figure out
whether to do this project or night not
first of all I mean it's her story is
set against what is actually the third
battle round the world the electric
current which is the hydroelectric plant
up at Niagara Falls but but beyond
everything I love the tone and
atmosphere of her Gilded Age I thought
she really got it right so a line long
is trying trying to pretend I'm in JP
Morgan's private Pullman I'm rereading
the City of Light to get the right frame
of mind I get into Buffalo it's in the
winter so it's and you know arriving the
evening is dark already go to my hotel
which was downtown I ate and went to bed
because I had a business busy and big
day the next day at 2 o'clock in the
morning I was woken up from was just the
most ferocious thunder and lightning
storm I have ever seen in my life and
this hotel room had very large picture
windows and I was pretty high up like on
the eighth floor ceiling and I got up
and looked out and these Gilded Age
buildings that were below me we just all
this thunder and lightning is crashing
down well I decided that this was Nikola
Tesla expressing himself because he
loved lightning meaning you know
lightning to him was the expression of
electricity and Buffalo was the city of
his greatest triumph which was the
development of alternating current and
it's transmission from this
hydroelectric plant into the City of
Buffalo and what I didn't know as I was
watching this amazing display and
telling myself a Nikola Tesla that in
fact the
very building where this wonderful
electrical soiree and banquet was held
setting him right after the first
transmission of electrical power was in
the Ellicott building and I did not know
that that building not only was it still
around but it was really like just
blocks from where I was staying and I
found out the next morning if I just you
know was very thrilled I rushed right
down there and it was obviously not in
the state it wasn't its glory data but
it had been refurbished and everything
that I had read about this building that
was magnificent about it was still there
it's a building that was designed by
Daniel Hudson Burnham who was the
creator of the World's Fair the white
city of 1893 and a very famous Chicago
architect this had been the largest
office building in the world in 1896 was
its claim to fame and it had an
incredible interior courtyard which you
can still see of this beautiful stained
glass ceiling and then these really
incredible elevators with these bar
relief bronze doors with all kinds of
scenes from you know from Pier Niagara
and New York so that was that was really
a thrill to see these actual places and
feel that Nikola Tesla have been present
now when you actually go to Niagara
Falls of course Stanford White's
Cathedral in power which have housed
these original a hydroelectric plant is
gone and all that's left oddly is this
little building which is a miniature of
that which was a transformer building
and I know some dreamer has bought this
building and warehouse it with this
vision of someday opening a museum and I
don't
exactly what the status of that is but I
suspect it's still sitting there waiting
for the return of glory and then of
course there's always the big statue of
Niagara Falls of Nikola Tesla which is
fun but what I mainly remember is going
to the Niagara Falls public library
which has a very good local history
section and there were some very
wonderful and unique Tesla items but
mainly the librarian bitterly telling me
if he had not come if he had not
invented electricity New York State
would still be the really important
place it had been because everyone
wouldn't have gone south to the Sun Belt
because there wouldn't be
air-conditioning ok oh so I was right
working on one of the reasons I would
subtracted the Gilded Age I think you
know as the 1990s progressed it was
really an era that resonated to our own
time I mean both these eras there was
just extraordinary technological
advances that really spurred big
revolutions in the way people live and
work I mean obviously electricity is a
much bigger revolution than the internet
but the Internet is a big revolution and
the other thing was really a great
challenge as a writer and that was to
try and write a book where you took
something that everyone doesn't give a
second thought to electricity and try
and take them back to a time when it was
really exotic when it was very expensive
when it was something that was great
luxury so that was a very enjoyable to
me as a historian to try and kind of
grep recreate that age it was a joy to
spend two years with these three men I
mean they were really extraordinary and
to me each of them was so American and
very unique and brilliant in their own
way so you Edison at this time is
already the world's greatest
Venter ultimately ended up with 1093
patents which remains the most patents
that any American has so he's still like
the champion of the Patent Office he is
a completely self-made wonderfully
folksy he was the beloved of the
newspapers he just had a tremendous way
with words he started this life as a
newsboy he was to train himself to be a
crack telegrapher and primarily created
himself as as an inventor and an amazing
sense of PR and he was such an optimist
one of my favorite esterline is later in
life his whole Lab burned down out in
Orange Park in Orange New Jersey and if
this is his quote
aw shucks it's alright we've just got
rid of a lot of old rubbish I mean you
have to really love someone like that he
also was incredibly important in the
sense of bringing about his marriage
between science and corporate America
one of the reasons Edison prevailed over
all competitors is he had the money and
he had the money because Wall Street
backed him the other thing it was very
fond about this book was thing Edison
really at his darkest his most ruthless
I mean that's not the way we think of
him and so I call this Edison for
grown-ups
and then there's Nikola Tesla who most
of us have never heard of I know him
because I'd had a student in a writing
class who wrote a paper about him
because there's a band called Tesla and
their new little something about him he
was amazingly hot very highly educated
in contrast either Edison or
Westinghouse he was an Edison employee
who tried to get Edison to adopt a'ti
Edison was so proud of his brilliance in
developing this entire system of
lighting he could not bring himself
to admit that someone had a better
system Tesla was just this fabulous
eccentric couldn't be a bear to be in
the room with a woman wearing curls he
liked everything divisible by three so
when he would swim laughs he would never
swim 26 laps in Sweden 27 laps if he
stayed in a hotel and lived in an
apartment the world number had to be
divisible by 3 he had great phobia of
germs he died almost any given night
that he was in New York and either
Delmonico's or Walter Waldorf he would
have a big pile of pristine napkins and
he would take one and use each one to
clean off his knives forks and plates
and glasses and what-have-you
he was incredibly ahead of his time in
terms of his adventure and in the end of
all his many inventions and he was
really a visionary only AC with other
fully developed and one of the other
things that peak was Tesla was really
charming if he has a big cult following
do things like talk about how he
probably was a space alien because he
was so far ahead of his time that's the
only explanation you know that you could
have and then finally there's George
Westinghouse who I have to say was the
one I liked best of all these three
which maybe is not the right thing to
say here into Todd when the home of
Edison I knew nothing about Westinghouse
I just thought of him as a brand name on
refrigerators and air conditioners but
he was really this very charismatic and
reckless entrepreneur and in an era of
robber barons he had a tremendous
concern for his own workers which was
very touching and he was only really
cared about having cutting-edge products
you know if his product wasn't as good
as it should be he would throw it all
out and just move on to the next thing
and what my favorite of his sayings was
impossible is not a word in my
vocabulary so he would go out and commit
him
doing things come back to Pittsburgh and
his workers were just appalled and yet
they were so inspired by him and loved
to work with him to somehow another they
would come up with a solution
the interesting thing about Westinghouse
is ultimately I think he represents much
more than Edison modern corporate
science and the reason is very
straightforward he was very willing to
collaborate with other people and
recognize that other people's inventions
or ideas were better than his
so advocate when he thought of Tesla had
invented you know a really wonderful
system if they see and it figured out
how to use alternating current in a
motor he bought all his patents hired
him at the consultants and between the
two of them they figured out the system
of electricity that is the basis of
electricity to this day all over the
world which is pretty amazing a
technological advance that has lasted
for a century the other thing I love
about wetting Fe was very dedicated to
his wife's Tesla's biggest love with a
white pigeon Edison I think you could
safely say was fairly chronically
neglectful but Westinghouse set up both
the telegraph and telephone so that no
matter where he was in the world and he
traveled a great deal he could always
call his wife every day and I think
those of us who were married have to
think that that's a nice thing first
very sad when I finished this book
because I knew that was the end of my
days and I suppose I should say night
with the Edison Tesla and Westinghouse
and as you can imagine I'm now back
spending my days with Alexander Cassatt
and the title of this book the working
title is conquering Gotham and I said
also you know not like another book of
Gilded Age titles and technology which
I'm enjoying a great deal but I think
you know I think I think there's always
going to be very deep spot in my heart
for Empire to slide so that's the back
story vampires allies I'd be happy to
take any questions and thank you so much
for having me chocolates just gonna
delight
I was very excited
I strongly sharing his mania today my
how you have to learn the total food the
logical context for the place in the
country the mile long and mostly in
trouble a person to be familiar to you
the other day I acquired that uses right
up by 100 we can recite a little in your
book into life that change by holding
them tight quarters and question have
person through college in return for
five years working poems or shared on
his races 1930 and everybody else only
personal areas and reflect Alex at my
father and his apartment his place for
safe hat and Maltese on the same
cocktail and the Shakalaka cheese which
I was pregnant attached by a bloke who
nothing had so we had a little more not
allowed in the woman's experiment he had
a partner skeleton switch to terminal 2
P column K through war and said time
that I survived eight to five months or
penises there he was not selected
Robertson
seven Weston panel books that have
little in report planet and I would like
to see your same hair and now my
threatened the Westinghouse Museum it's
as in Wilmerding and on the internet
just putting George Westinghouse Museum
and they'll come up and they're really a
repository for what's left I do it's
very astonishing to me discover when I
began to research is the Westinghouse
corporation can exist anymore that it
was dismantled in 1996 in the way so
many companies were but this is a museum
that's run by volunteers and they're
very dedicated and actually what I was
going to say is that I was in a state of
all near panic as I was finishing you
know toward the integrating this book
because it was just so hard to find
anything about Westinghouse he was not a
man who left any papers no letters I got
more wedding house letters in the Edison
archive then I do anywhere else you know
between the two of them and their
company and in the end I when I was
really finished everything else I went
to will begin to use this archive and
the people who run it really have almost
no idea what Senate and but they were
very kind and generous and they just
opened this huge vault and they said
well you know whatever you want to look
at and then they just left me by myself
and gave me
well my I had my daughter with me as my
xeroxing expert and you know whatever I
wanted to Xerox that would be fine and I
had this really really rare experience a
historian which is low and behold there
was something no one knew existed which
was a huge oral history project which
was done by the company in the 1930s
where they interviewed every person
who'd ever
had anything to do with whether she was
still alive and then really saved me
because from that there were first-hand
reports for Reginald Belfield who was
you know the original help design test
and develop of is the first and original
transformer with George Westinghouse so
this was just historical goal I mean one
thing after another on those lines and I
came home with oh my god you know I
finally you know good quote impossible
is not in my vocabulary before I found
this I did not know if George
Westinghouse himself had actually ever
been to the Chicago World's Fair to see
his own incredible achievement because
in all the coverage of the World's Fair
there's never any mention of him once
the fair open and it was only through
the interviews with the man who managed
their World's Fair that I found out that
he did eventually go in the middle of
the fair with his wife but all he was
really interested it was looking at
everything electrical he never went to
anything ceremonial wasn't interested in
getting any kind of a claim um never
gave almost a public speech in his whole
life until he lost his electrical
company to Wall Street predators and so
in his he died in 1914 many people said
of a broken heart from losing as an
electrical company in the Progressive
Era he became kind of a crusader for
government regulation of Wall Street
because he felt as if his company was
stolen from him either man mentioned it
mentioning General
you know that that was the other I don't
know how are we doing for time here okay
well actually Eric Larson is a friend's
mom because he used to live in Baltimore
and we were writing our books at the
same time so and I really loved reading
his book because I only could devote a
certain amount of time to researching
the world fair where he devoted great
amount of time and so I really just
enjoyed reading the full story of daniel
hudson berman and the whole tale of the
fair and we were also reading at the
same time these Chicago papers about the
fair and one of the real pleasures of
working in the Gilded Age is it was an
era when the only way people learn
things was from newspapers and so the
papers went into a level of detail about
everything that you can't imagine today
because they had to tell you what people
look like what they wore what the
weather felt like so much of this comes
through to you now through television or
on radio or whatever reporters don't
feel obliged to tell you these things
anymore
and newspapers had very distinctive
personalities I mean they some
newspapers were very Republicans some
were very democratic some you know we're
very focused on scandal so you know
reading the different papers and so the
World's Fair coverage of the Chicago
papers was was quite different and
actually the the best paper was the
Chicago ocean record I mean Chicago
ocean don't know where that that
newspaper title came from but so
arrogantly had many enjoyable chats
about
that and it was just you know great fun
yes you are looking for another project
you didn't hear about Westinghouse went
very cottagey bills late is sponsor 1971
Jack well that over General Electric vs
e company robot on par and yet be able
to happen but they have one on the road
my Jesus so you might want to get
approximation comparative what happened
101 blob recent of history for me I like
to live in longer go than that
so I grew back and forth I guess ok the
end of a guidance we actually recovered
on the tops of these people of the
tariff rate of the culvert to access to
the acidity I don't think the issue of
public access came about until the
electricity was really contemplate
actually one of the things it was really
surprising to me I I I believe the
figure is that in 1908 only 8 percent of
American houses had electricity so it
was a pretty slow process the places
that got electricity quick most quickly
were obviously commercial enterprises
and then after that came household and
the issue of the right to electricity
really came to a head I think in the
issue of rural electrification because
the question was you know who was going
to spend that sums of money to get
electricity to people where it wasn't
really
Alec and I don't I have to say I don't
feel really very well-informed in that
but having just happened to look in some
electric journals for different kinds of
things I do remember seeing in the
thirties when this was a really hot
issue with FDR and he really rammed it
through some very bitter ads in these
journals run by electric utilities
basically denouncing the idea that the
government was invading what they saw as
their turf and going into the generation
of electricity and this was socialism
and so forth but I don't think it I
don't think it became an issue until
electricity was commonplace enough and
in the poly majority of American homes
that the feeling rose that really it was
it would should be something that
everyone was entitled to so that's the
best things working together yeah thank
you for your IQ today the wonderful
degrees Apple we had access we were it
is brought back that Tesla at one point
these neighbors who let you have those
heavy financial difficulties but Texans
the Sorum contract that I would work
together on
and consequently two team members will
enjoy financial rewards in the future
both as men work and help women what in
character how you climb up he may be
licensed isolated he helped him know I
mean I guess that's actually the one to
me the one unanswered question or the
you know the mystery as I said by and
large Westinghouse was an
extraordinarily decent man I mean to
this day in Pittsburgh I think you've
got a sense of this with the woman who
spoke first he's really kind of a
revered character and his company is
still really respected and there's a
great sort of morning that the company
that cares so much about its employees
is gone but it's very clear no it never
made that good I don't know why later in
life when Westinghouse was long gone he
died in 1914 and Tesla lived on until
1946 the company became so embarrassed
by Tesla's penury
that they gave him what I think you have
to say is a quite a niggling pension
sort which is they paid his rent at The
New Yorker Hotel now in contrast GE for
whom William Stanley work when he was on
hard times
gave him a pension of $1,000 a month
which must have been a lot of money you
know in the 20s and 30s so that wasn't
adjusted the template had he gotten his
royalties it was a calculated he would
have made seventeen million dollars so
he gave up a vast fortune hey it's a
very you kind of ugly part of the story
and for which I I don't
as long as planning to you know you
think oh you'll get an answer decision
bar that's what I'm frustrations about
being a historian you have lots of
questions and many of them just never do
answered and that was one that never got
answered for me kids doing it okay well
first of all was here he realized that a
sitar had one great advantage to that
dispensation a water clock power very
high moment of the world doesn't family
with hardwood we also remember the text
offer alone for practice today so Edison
bought out the family works late intense
office located in Pittsfield
Massachusetts and they also use these
for coolant most as pharmaceuticals
apparently personal as the same total
to request me out at the same time
Edison with a mathematician of self
hired Charles Proteus assignments at the
time to relentless serious saying that
when on the alternative characters did
not happen with the red card time that
sat down and what Edison by the time was
a acknowledge the fact that he biggest
reason and assignments worked out a lot
of the mathematical systems that are
electrical engineers we now we just high
school for calculating and I working a
little motors department here in
Pennsylvania and we both ammonia uncle
Reading Railroad I never left my house
General Electric so in Erie Pennsylvania
a little motor compartment are also
pregnancy massage and a lot of
electrical operation right ourselves to
the customer
I wasn't understand
I had this question the first was both
ah faceted crystals modest financial
generation mm and we live in survival
genus and solicitor mr. Tesla he was
already well now about Tesla is that he
you know film is very mysterious tower
30 tower or something like that and he
went to JP Morgan telling him that this
was going to be a radio he was working
on radio and this was a broadcasting now
JP Morgan had a lot and you know various
investors affiliated with him had a lot
of money wrapped up in the standard you
know electrical development and because
he was one of Edison's earliest backers
and as soon as Marconi transmitted
across the ocean I mean at that point
then JP Morgan lost all interest well
then Tesla confess us well this is not
really just about radio it's really bad
energy transmission but you know tells I
had a very track record as someone who
saw his inventions through he was a
visionary in the sense he was really
interested in the larger cosmic
questions having to do with electricity
electricity was his passion and under
and electricity with his passion and he
wasn't really in his heart of hearts
interested for instance in making a
better light bulb very early on he had
invented what was a proto fluorescent
light and so for instance John Jacob
Astor I don't know the fourth or third
or gave him you know a reasonable sized
amount of money to develop this light
and Tesla took that money went to
Colorado Springs and did a lot of cosmic
visionary electrical investigations and
then we turn to New York with no further
progress on the proto fluorescent light
and so you know after just washes hands
of them though he did let him continue
to live in this hotel and never pay any
rent until they finally evicted him took
the mortgage on the Wardenclyffe Tower
and then blew up the Wardenclyffe Tower
so the land would be worth something I
mean castles life is a drama such as you
can only hope for as a writer I just
after I sent in my manuscript to my
agent he sent me back this email and he
said this man is an awesome stream but
it's heartbreaking I mean it's a
heartbreaking story really to this day
no one quite knows with tesla how much
of this stuff that he invented really
could have ever been made real but
actually one thing you have to know is
he died in the middle of World War two
and the US government immediately
confiscated most of his files and so you
wonder you know where are his files I
don't think really people know and
they're so you know this all really
feeds into you know these kind of
conspiracy theories and part of this was
because Tesla Tesla was saying that he
had invented a death ray and this would
solve the problem for world peace and
you know we would have the death ray and
people would have
repent dozen so an tesla system a
serious character that it's hard to have
definitive knowledge of what he really
did and didn't know but i mean just
imagine that if it's 1890 nikola tesla
has invented remote control he he held
demonstration it was in Madison Square
Garden the old one he made a big huge
pond and on have you put a giant boat
and he stood back and he just made this
boat move around where we wanted the
light flashed on and off no and people
thought it was magic and he didn't mind
let it have him people think it was
magic he liked to be called a wizard now
if Thomas Edison had invented remote
control you would have had the remote
control you know carrots door that went
up and down or something he would have
done something with it but see Tesla was
really kind of happy to amaze people
with it and then go back to his lab and
continue on and he was actually way
ahead of Marconi on on the writ on radio
but his lab burned down just as he was
about to you know really step forward
and ultimately Marconi got after Tesla
said Marconi got into a fight with the
US government over his patent the
government wanted to develop radio for
some war application and he took the
government to court and and he lost the
Supreme Court said no the original
passes belong to Tesla well temple was
dead so it didn't do him much good but
you know it gives you an idea and type
of problem but one of the the other
discoveries for me or revelations about
working on this book was the
litigiousness of these men
Edison really had a huge leg up because
he had a lot of lawyers and boy he went
after people and Westinghouse was the
same and in fact actually one of the
reasons the GE and Westinghouse began to
cooperate was essentially because it
cost them so much money their legal fees
were so gigantic they simply had to come
terms on patent sharing but that is what
Tesla did not have he did not have
lawyers and for that reason people just
fell free to infringe on his inventions
he was very okay I don't know I go I
fortunately I don't know I need to talk
with her in fact it turned out always
been pronouncing his wife's name wrong
like their name was nina miller but it's
minor I think so no I don't know
anything about Edison he's looking at it
some from someplace here on his banner
[Music]
Thanks
chill Jones other books include South
Bronx rising and hepcats
narcs and pipe dreams empires of light
is published by Random House while US
soldiers currently fight in Afghanistan
and Iraq
America's earlier